hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
central concepts for epictetus is stoic
philosophy particularly his ethics and
you'll see why it's so central in just a
moment it is what in Greek is called Pro
a racist this is a tournament Aristotle
used it had a very important role to
play in his moral philosophy Epictetus
tapes it and expands you know it to mean
something even more encompassing and
really places at the core of the human
person it's going to get translated in
English depending on who is doing the
work of translating and something like
Faculty of choice like I have here will
faculty that will moral purpose a number
of different things sometimes just
translated his mind as well which could
be a bit misleading now there's a lot to
say about this this shows up in so many
of the chapters of the four books of
epictetus discourses and these are some
of the key points that I wanted to hit
up you can think of it as the overall
structure of the highest human and also
epictetus is quite clear this is
something to share
with God or the gods it's a divine
faculty at one point he says that this
is in fact a piece of God within the
otherwise animal human nature the
program racist is not something
radically distinct for epictetus from
the other things that he talked about as
the high especially the ruling faculty
or the rational faculty but you could
think of it as a different side of it
the side that places the emphasis on
choice the effects of our choices and
our actions and intentions the
structuring that takes place over time
so it encompasses for example the
aversions and desires the a these
effective being drawn towards something
being judged to be a good that's a
desire this sort of a withdrawing or
pushing away effectively from something
that we we deemed to be an evil choices
themselves all fall within this matrix
so you can think of it as you know the
overall structure that's formed by
choices but also in what we use to make
an individual choice judgments don't
Matta hoop ellipses in Greek these are
quite important as well and how we judge
things is not simply necessitated in a
mechanical process where input comes in
and we have to spew that output out we
have some control over the the black box
part of it you might say the central
part and how we process things and
arrive at each other that's how we also
use our older judgments which might be
good ones or might be bad ones like
reliable like the unreliable and all of
these things stick together there
there's a nexus coming together here in
the Faculty of choice the prior asus
epictetus will actually say and at some
points in book one that this
is what the person is so this is at the
core of the human being we might you
know to use different terms today
depending on what you mean by
personality saying that it is the
personality itself you know there's a
variety of language that we could use
now it's formed both by habituation so
by doing something over and over again
or by breaking oneself of habits that's
more often fantastic has to be the case
you substitute a habit or another but
you have to do that by making choices
there's a reflexivity to this because
you were using only with other faculties
you are using the very faculty to work
upon itself now this also means we don't
start out looking a great state so you
can think of it as using the very you
know set of tools to expand the set of
tools and to get rid of the bad tools
and to fix the toolbox so that things
aren't falling out you know we can given
with other metaphors but that notion of
reflexivity that when i choose for
myself i am choosing i'm not only using
the Faculty of will
I'm also choosing how I'm going to be
using that faculty it will later what's
going to be available to me what I'm
cutting off from I can choose to you
know generate good habits I can choose
to generate bad habits although would be
in a rather irrational for being to
cultivate bad habits knowing that
they're bad habits
but you get the idea that it's
habituation and the exercise of choice
now the goal for the stomach philosophy
from the beginning is to live in
accordance with nature and epictetus
doesn't use the word lives all so much
we're talking about a life he talks
about a pro races but the pro racist is
structuring the entire life of a person
is formed over the course of the life
we modified is is what sort of sets the
moral horizons for us it's what we carry
from place to place and position to
position and relationship to
relationship so that we cannot get away
from it and the goal then is to do what
to bring it into harmony symphonia or to
bring it into accordance haha it's a
greek preposition with nature Cruces now
that doesn't mean to just live naturally
or do what comes naturally man because
you know in many respects as human
beings our habits have already been
formed poorly we inhabit societies and
cultures that tend to form us and form
us in ways that the Stoics consider to
be ultimately irrational and harmful for
us teaching us lessons about what really
matters and what doesn't matter that
deviates from from the realities of
things and so to live in accordance with
nature or to bring one's Faculty of
choice into accordance with with nature
means to bring it into accordance with
what human nature is when it's fully
developed not just you know eating and
you know rolling around and enjoying
yourself in the grass and all those
sorts of things being spontaneous it
really means thinking about what is a
human being and so this requires two
things it requires a lot of work in
order to restructure the desires the
inversions to you know bring the
judgments under control to an emotions
by the way for the Stoics are in fact
something that arises from judgments -
you know gradually have mastery or some
sort of rationality to our choices all
of that takes a lot of work worth
capitalized
Yeah right but it also takes a right
understanding of things and that's why
the stomach philosophy is there to
provide that that proper understanding
not only in terms of ethics but also in
terms of the you know well they come
logic or how to actually think these
matters through and not get taken in so
all of that has to do with with pro
races this is where there's another
important point this is where the real
good and the real evil for human beings
exists Epictetus stresses this over and
over and over again we tend to think
that that other things that are
extrinsic to our our faculty at will are
really good like wealth for example
we're having a nice body or health even
or you know holding office having a cool
shark board you know I mean if if to
take this as a great example if I think
that my good lies in here rather than in
my by a faculty will I've been in
trouble and notice I'm using my very
Faculty of will or choice to make that
thing a value they good to mistakenly
see it so this is where our a real good
and evil exist outside of the prior ASIS
there are the things that well you know
are not totally neutral aren't primarily
neither good nor evil they can be on the
class of the preferred they can be the
class of the rejected but they're
ultimately going to be traced back to
where the real locus of good and evil
are which is within the human person
within the the most determinative part
of the human person the part that is a
good the good news is we can in fact use
to work out itself so I have you know
two examples of this would be we can
choose how we deal with here is another
key stoic idea appearances external
it's also translated as Fantasia is the
Greek for imaginations we choose how we
address those and that's part of what
this faculty can can do right how we
fulfill our duties not only towards
their self but towards all sorts of
other people and if we believe in the
divine in relation to the divine as well
all of that is a matter of the pro eye
races because if you're choosing for
example not to fulfill your duties as a
father as a child as a spouse as a
citizen you are not placing your prior
ASUS in accordance with fully developed
human nature you may feel like you you
know you are being natural but you're
not really harmonizing with what you
know what is really there as far as
potential one other thing that I wanted
to sort of close on in chapter 17 of
what 1 there's this wonderful phrase
there that I think wraps all of this
particularly that reflexivity he talks
about a pro a racist compelling moral
purpose here should be program racist
compelled Pro a racist or moral purpose
compelled moral purpose or the Faculty
of choice compelled the Faculty of
choice the actual Greek for this is very
short you know to test deeper racing for
our basis
he's the verb there is a little bit
earlier and a non-constant compelled to
to you know to drive it's in the past
tense so that's why haven't passed us
here but the whole idea is that one of
the things that is so different about
this is the fact that it is indeed
reflexive we have a choice about what we
want our overall structure of our
faculty of choice to look like not just
here in the present where we don't we
can't radically change into the present
but for the future and the past doesn't
have to completely determine our present
for our future in that respect so if we
were a bad person in the past and we
realized that that's the case and we
understand the motivations the desires
the aversions the judgments that led to
man behavior we have the capacity to
change that we can use our currently not
so good moral purpose or for a racist to
compel itself to become a bit better we
do that by doing the work we do that by
choosing we do that through the
situation and we do that guided by the
right understanding which the stoical
philosophy is supposed to be providing
notice that part of that right
understanding is the existence of
pro-isis
and the nature of it